ciao
oggi andiamo anche le unghie
ho dovuto convincere italia perché
ovviamente non vuole mappare questo
video show presentava convinzione ciò
che stavo a metterti le unghie perché
alle ditte grandi e quindi mi raccomando
lo show the flight di supporto o
[Musica]
comunque è veramente il credito così
lunghi non si riesce a fare niente
infatti dovremo provare a fare lo slime
con le unghie lunghe e vince chi riesce
a non far cadere si succhia quindi alla
fine del video vedremo chi avrà più di
ancora intatte nelle mani ma io porto
svantaggiato non ho mai avuto se non più
così bene anch'io per imbucare quindi
chi ne avrebbe un look più lunga che
alla fine del video vincerà e ovviamente
voi potrete votare anche per la bellezza
del bus tra i loro racconti utenti con
questo biglietto non contentissimo
allora fatati e bob corn mettetevi cosi
team rosa blu celeste per me novità
vediamo
iniziamo ad aprire la colla fitto
incredibile stata incollata no no
incollata ce l'ho fatta
sì c'è riuscito io non ho veramente
stranissima
questo è un viola allora colorante
finalmente posso scegliere io il
colorante che non sarà verde finalmente
vediamo se ne escano aprirlo però si 67
a fare tutto andò a prenderli per
riprendere tutto tipo con sibilato non
riescono o non riesco a prendere gli
altri colori
così lunga fare cosa io prima corsa con
marasco di se invece cosi che si ok a
che allora viola si sono aggiunti sono
dati che della prossima che è mole così
il fatto come fatto fatti male che bel
viola perché perché perché vi ho detto
di sì dai primari che affezione le
unghie coppie da quel tempo non è che ti
fa male quando lunga a grato ma non fa
male perché devi fare questa cosa
leggera tutto di viola rientrato scuro
il colore non riesce a girare lunedì all
asse più belle e che si tirano su tipo
non so spiegarlo una sensazione strana
come servizio in modo aperto per un
lungo ma che attaccando miglia per
davvero la x a unghiate prova a mettere
la schiuma da barba
vediamo intende bozzetto pubblico
veniamo alla scocca è se non fatevi va
dai fattori ma sa anche il tappo figlio
vediamo con quanta grazia e delicatezza
e mischiando lager scherzando è però
abbassare la scuola hanno fatto lo psi
colori del nostro del maghetto del
cimitero tra perché io sono più rosa
anche se viola ho la pelle d'oca a
supporto
[Applauso]
e stato lui a me non è affatto così
tanto questi posti catanzaro vera perché
fa male allora voglio aggiungere delle
decorazioni e metto queste palline
aprirle la sua forma è impossibile
infatti addio è difficilissimo previsti
dai ti puoi salvare preferenza in più
bella del mio non solo faccia ce l'avevo
di questo caso è difficilissimo prima
tra fatta viva ieri che bello quello è
bronzo pronto celeste visto molto bene
ma lo so secondo me sì poi vorrei
aggiungere qualcos'altro ma perché ho
deciso di come ho fatto ad aprire la
bozzetta incredibile per più volte
castrata doppia allora proprio mettere
un po di lezione poi non vedo l'ora di
vedere i poking soprattutto fa a far
tutto
oddio dai nomi più a 16 fissile
schiacciarla se riuscite avete i
brillantini
incredibile vero
che cosa che non sono non provare e soci
sono queste clippers dovresti provare
con queste borsette sono ti lamenti che
fortuna beh io voglio aggiungere
qualcosa dai per questo video anche
discutere se potremo provare a fare
altre cose con le unghie lunghe di no io
non sono locale fare una torta
io sono d'accordo e vi piacciono tivoli
un box di cibo alla bocca un rigore
mentre l'inter ma da più di 20 st
bellissimo a me piace così inizia
l'articolo mi son cadute queste free sul
tavolo la state cercando di raccogliere
limite o dio se ti carica allora prendo
un attimo a trovare tutti ho letto i
vostri commenti dove milita di di
attivare temiamo lo slime perché lo
attivo troppo il fisco più attento
adesso che brave e l'inter asterix essi
ott io faccio troppo casini questo
tavolo devo sistemare bene niente a2
visto le bambine per the tourist faccia
aggiungere altro
oddio ma praticamente distaccata vediamo
altre banda che gli offro per quanto
durerà si no mi sembra un tricolore è il
caso saccardo toccata come faccio poi
diciamo poi a mettere logica star o meno
ma quella sarà la parte più divertente
mare in pochi a youtube accade qualcosa
anche per le unghie v0 io ma aspettiamo
perché andiamo là a fare il booking
torino per hanno grosse e le decorazioni
viola insieme ai glitter bronzo che ne
so io metto il colorante viola il
colorante rosa schiuma da barba e
paragone con latte grandi e piccole di
sicuro le elezioni perché partizione mr
gli dissi devo provare a prenderla in
maniera differente
fini si sta a casa non sono sporcati da
ieri tra di noi ancora no di fatto deve
fare cosa 90
comunque se mi state chiedendo se poi ho
trovato la cioccolata del video del
mistery box no all'inter nella nascosta
ovviamente non l'ho ancora trovata lo
sapete di cosa sto parlando andato a
vedere l'invito delle mistery box che
abbiamo due misere bar dove si è
attaccato 4
non sono riuscito a far filare che bel
colore e ben di dio è impossibile da
mischiare con le varie nudo l'ora di
vederti si doveva fare un pochino così
scherzato la gente si sono staccate
[Musica]
stessa canada un diamo si sono spostate
è difficile far sentire istoniense
merita neanche nominato perché me la mia
considero messo gli stacca volo secondo
kevin e ora vogliamo sentire un po di
foche in calc iniziato a torino sono
ancora grato
ok ed invero in 31 30 se volete potete
provare anche voi a casa lasciando lo
slime ma rischiano così un po me
racconta sempre la recente entrata è
prontissimo il mio è pronto
per facendo è stupendo e bellissimo no
questo secondo è rimasta di sinistra
ovvio che orrore
questo farà parte dello slam
allora decorazione aggiuntivo cazzo è
staccato un pezzo di scotch no ma io
adesso posso fare un po da tutte le mani
anche con le unghie o in questo senso
non ce l'ha il loro ok ragazzi di ceo
vediamo un po che adesso mr riscoperte
unghie enormi allora questo è il mio
time il colore bellissimo vediamo un po
ormai è un po particolare
che strana sopra cristo
aspettando con le lunghe che non stai
usando
[Musica]
dobbiamo stringere
gli indizi emersi iniziato che non
riesco a fare molto rumore con queste
mucche rode no si stava staccando una un
altro così simonian
[Musica]
quindi questo il mio slime anche molto
di date da 1 a 10 tocca vitale ecco
almeno un aspetto tutti vicini anche
l'altra si sta staccando ed ho disastro
disastro gli effetti un altra no
e ora il mio è un celeste bellissimo
vive col con dei glitter bronzo
e poi ci sono queste conchigliette color
rosso violaceo il senato ne moto 8
carino molto molto bello lo attivato di
meno come potete vedere super
allungabile questa volta anche troppo
poi vediamo che poi preso occhi nel
frattempo sto perdendo la terza un piano
andiamo avanti colpo king
nuovo incredibile crono devi parenti con
le unghie però non è giusto adesso
bravissimo perdendo anche la quarta
unghia dai tutte dentro tutte le
trendline che era stata cavallini altra
si sta staccando ora una quale ecco
quindi però non persa 3 nella quarta qui
che sta andando lì a lei è però lo slime
diventa più decorato con un p ha finto
che allora che hanno pensato del mio
slide bellissima del porting poi
guardate animati che bello è che senza
qualcosa non ti metti a picchiarla ad
occupare lo schermo snelli e una fiat
600 con questa volta però dai guardare
la bellezza la bellezza del colore
i colori scelti sono magnifici quei
pochi ma che cos'è l'amore ho imparato a
fare in pochi allora quante uniti sono
rimasti fate un che perso 33
tra queste ancora qui è perché io non so
come ma vi sono ritrovata senza tre e
che ha non so quando si è successo
quindi siamo un pò guardà centro non si
è ancora spenta la mantiene quindi pari
siamo pari ti piacciono perché unghie
lunghe ti piacerebbe tenere il gruppo no
se non mi piace vi lascio qua il
sondaggio per portare chi ha vinto the
victory lo strumento vitale e mara mi
lascia un po a quattro cartellini
disastro certo c'è l'altro che bella
maglietta nostre altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite
buona visione